[Musik]
das internet hat die medienwelt radikal
verändert informierten sich die menschen
früher aus wenigen massenmedien und den
publikationen großer verlagshäuser
so bietet das netz heute eine
gigantische fülle an
informationsmöglichkeiten neue
meinungsmacher treten hervor blogger und
youtube stars mit großem einfluss und
sie fordern die klassischen
meinungsmacher des fernsehens unter
presse heraus sieht so der journalismus
der zukunft aus und leben wir überhaupt
noch in einer gemeinsamen wirklichkeit
darüber rede ich mit dem youtube
wieso
[Musik]
wieso wie fühlt sich das an
bei einem traditionellen sender zu
setzen ein anderes t-shirt anziehen zu
müssen weil es zur kamera nicht passt
und so das gefühl in eine völlig andere
welt gekommen zu sein ja aber ich meine
ich ja doch definitives andere welt vor
einigen mit anderen maßstäben also da
die die die qualität wird anders
gemessen und die also nicht nur die
herangehensweise sind anders und
sozusagen das was man was man anstrebt
ist auch anders glaubst du dass diese
welt eines tages stirbt oder vielleicht
schon in naher zukunft glaube ich nicht
schallplatten sterben auch nicht aus
keine ahnung nur nur weil etwas alt ist
heißt nicht dass es auch sterben muss ja
aber das ist vielleicht seine funktion
als leitmedium einbüßt und dann
irgendwie sowie bestimmte vinylplatten
sowas special effects oder für special
interest ist das scheint ja gerade so zu
laufen ja dass das ist ja das worauf es
hinausläuft aber ich glaube dass
sozusagen also die die ihren gehens
weise so zu drehen hier die wird nicht
aussterben
die machen nämlich manche leute auf auf
youtube zum zum zum beispiel auch also
es ist jetzt nicht so es ist ja eine
herangehensweise von vielen so und ich
glaube dass es immer leute geben die
diese herangehensweise mögen werden wenn
es aber jetzt sozusagen darum geht das
fernsehen also nicht so zu drehen
sondern dass man ein kasten zu hause hat
wo man einschalten da läuft den tag über
was und man muss es sich aufnehmen oder
man muss halt wenn wir uns nochmal sehen
will müsste man sich irgendwie auf ich
weiß nicht was ich weiß nicht wie ein
fernseher laufen ob diese können aber
ich glaube das war einfach aussehen weil
das featureset schlechter ist also das
ist ja faktisch schlechter ein lineares
fernsehen zu sehen
finde ich und du gehörst ja dann der
welt an
also bist du eine promi in einer welt
die möglicherweise das fernsehen
vielleicht ja auch die traditionelle
presse april gesagt wie fühlt sich das
an
ich bin ja promi wenn man es jetzt
einfach zu sagen will
auf youtube aber zum also dass dass das
medium dass das lineare fernsehen
ablösen wird ist ja nicht youtube
sondern ist
online videos on demand zu gucken und
das habt ihr in der mediathek auch also
sozusagen die mediathek wird einfach das
lineare fernsehen mit der zeit ablösen
weil immer mehr leute in die mediathek
switchen werden das glaube ich ich
glaube nicht dass youtube die mediathek
vom von den öffentlich-rechtlichen oder
so ablösen wird oder irgend sowas dass
das glaube ich naja sagen wir mal wie
wenig gucke was videos gemacht auch
politischen inhalts zerstörung der cdu
die zur führung der presse die haben
krieg zahlen von ich glaube zum teil das
dass das ältere von beiden über 10
millionen also ein gewaltige resonanz
man kann vermuten tendenziell eher bei
jüngeren leuten wahrscheinlich etwas
weniger bei älteren leuten dann könnte
man doch vermuten dass youtube und und
dass menschen die das machen wie du
irgendwann die große meinungsmacher der
republik sein werden die aktuellen
sozusagen meinungsführer die sind
dermaßen mächtig dass das glaube ich
nicht mal eben so schnell geht also ich
meine söhne dpa hat eine riesige macht
so die öffentlich rechtlichen haben
riesige macht axel springer aller junge
das sind leute die haben mit ihr haben
milliarden in der hinterhand wenn sie
wollten um zu pushen dass sie ihre
meinungsmacht erhalten können und ich
bin einfach ein kleiner kerkow in meinem
wohnzimmer
also ich also ich glaube nur weil es da
so ein zwei sachen gab die ein bisschen
besser liefen wäre es ein bisschen naiv
zu glauben dass ich hier jetzt im dass
ich jetzt ganz alleine gegen solche
mächtigen leute irgendwie was bieten
aber dieser kleine coco hat gewaltige
reaktionen ausgelöst
also nicht nur weil der cdu sondern eben
auch bei der presse gut ausgezeichnet
worden mit dem henri nannen preis also
mir ist im deutschen journalismus nicht
möglich machst du deine rolle da nicht
ein bisschen klein
naja ich glaube nicht dass ich meine
rolle klein mache wenn ich sage die die
auswirkung war kraft aber ich glaube
nicht dass ich jetzt der neue
meinungsführer bin
das glaube ich nicht mir geht es
eigentlich darum zu verstehen was seine
gesellschaftliche rolle oder funktion
ist also wenn du über die zerstörung der
presse spricht dann meinst du ja glaube
ich nicht nur dazu die presse zerstört
sondern auch das die presse selber
zerstörerisches anrichtet und ich glaube
genau so hast du das so habe ich das
jedenfalls verstanden auch bei der cdu
dann hat man doch den eindruck in beiden
videos du möchtest einem gewissen
meinungs- kartell die stirn bieten und
mal sagen was nun wirklich sache ist
das ist doch die klassische rolle des
aufklärers ja ich also ich möchte schon
mit solchen sachen aufklärung ich möchte
schon mit solchen sachen nicht nur die
anderen aufteilen sollen mich selber
auch aufklären am anfang von dem video
steht ja immer ich möchte mich damit
auseinandersetzen ich weiß ja nicht was
dabei rumkommt ich weiß nicht was ich
dann finden werde so das heißt ich
möchte mich selbst kenne ich mich ja nun
aufklären ich sehe da natürlich auch ein
bisschen eine verantwortung weil ich
habe eine reichweite und jetzt nur
unterhaltung zu machen mit einer
reichweite denk mir wäre schon cool wenn
ich mir auch müssen mehr mühe geben weil
es dinge ist mit diesem mit den videos
mache ich ja kein geld oder so ich hab
da ja eigentlich nicht von steckte aber
ultra viel zeit rein so und dass das
mache ich natürlich in irgendeiner form
auch weil ich die verantwortung spüre
dass ich da irgendwie zeit rein stecken
sollte weil es was sind was sinnvolles
ist was einen konstruktiven diskurs
auslösen könnte oder mit mit gestalten
könnte wo ich einfach einen kleinen
kleinen beitrag dazu leisten kann
ja aber da denkt kleiner beitrag fächer
in eine bestimmte zeit also ihr fällt in
eine zeit in der die deutungsmacht der
etablierten medien immer stärker in die
krise gerät
es gibt immer mehr leute die nicht mehr
glauben was in der zeitung steht oder
dem fernsehen nicht mehr glauben und so
was vielleicht am ende noch sich selber
glauben oder gar nichts mehr glauben und
in diese zeit fällt das jahr ein also
wir erleben diesen großen medialen
umbruch früher war die medienwelt eine
sehr kontrollierte ein indem sie das ist
sehr wenig fern sich also sehr früher
sehr wenig fernsehprogramme gab
das ist sehr wenig meinungsführer unter
zeitungen gab und heute gibt es die
möglichkeit sich aus millionen von
quelle neben mit einem mausklick zu
informieren das ist ja eine gewaltige
veränderung und in diese veränderung
fällt das was du machst rein und das
verleiht dem jahr eine große
gesellschaftliche bedeutung mal völlig
egal wie groß selber eine bedeutung
einschätzt aber es fällt ja nicht in
irgendeinem ruhige zeit sondern es fällt
in die zeit eines medialen umbruchs
ja es hat insofern eine aussagekraft und
insofern bestimmtes
ein bestimmtes gewicht und ich verstehe
auch dass man es sozusagen
stellvertretend auch für im
grundsätzlichen pro einen
grundsätzlichen prozess sehen kann der
über allem auch steht das sehe ich schon
diese prozess sehen würde ich versuchen
gerne genauer zu verstehen
also was mir auffällt daran ist dass ich
denke der begriff der glaubwürdigkeit
oder der begriff der authentizität so
sehr große schlüsselbegriffe in dieser
medienrevolution ja und ich hatte ja
auch gerade gesagt dass ich den eindruck
habe dass die menschen aus je mehr
quälen sie sich informieren können um so
mehr etablierten meinungsmachern oder
meinungs- medien misstrauen so dass du
das so ähnlich sehen und bestätigen wie
groß ist ein misstrauen
ich hab zwei fragen ja eine frage ist ja
ich sehe es auch so dass in den letzten
jahren dieses grundsätzliche misstrauen
und medien gegenüber auf jeden fall
zunimmt das war ja auch meine große
sorge weshalb ich dann die die die
zerstörung der presse gemacht habe weil
ich natürlich weil es viele gründe gibt
wo die presse gar nichts dafür kann dass
ihnen misstraut wird aber es gibt eben
auch ein paar gründe die ich genannt
habe wo ich sehe hier werde die
verantwortung vielleicht wenn ihr das
und das sein lässt läuft besser und das
war ja da so ein bisschen falls mir ein
unglaublich wichtig ist das vertrauen in
die etablierten presse nicht einfach
unternehmen sinkt das ich glaube das
wird sich nicht gut aus deswegen war mir
das ein anliegen also die wind stehen
nicht das verschwinden der etablierten
presse sollte wünsche dir eine bessere
etablierte presse
natürlich habe ich glaube das hat auch
jeder verstand meinem video ich glaube
das habe ich denke dass jetzt für die
zuschauer nach soja der presse ja genau
und die andere frage war ist vergessen
er ich bin so schlecht merken da ging es
um die frage wie glaubwürdig glauben ob
ich dem leben presse glaub ja das ding
ist halt ich habe vorher noch so
anderthalb jahren etablieren presse
extrem krass geglaubt und dann habe ich
halt also ich habe sie nicht so viel
gelesen aber ihr schon geglaubt noch
etwas steht dann steht aber aus und doch
die schon das wird dann so stimmen und
dann habe ich halt viele artikel über
mich so gelesen weil es mich auch
interessiert was schreiben sie über mich
aber super oft gemerkt dass da einfach
falsche sachen drin standen was ich dann
auch in dem video
anspreche und das hat so ein bisschen in
mir echt losgelöst sodass ich dass ich
seitdem mehr den den etablierten medien
misstraue was ich schade finde
weil diese ganzen falschaussagen über
mich im grunde genommen zwei quellen
haben oder fast immer zwei quellen haben
würde ich unterstellen dass eine ist
absolute schlampigkeit also wirklich
einfach ich gucke mir eine sache nicht
mal an sondern sie irgendwie ja ich
glaube das geht da und darum nicht
einfach los was ich auch nachvollziehen
kann nachvollziehen dass das passiert
weil die leute haben unglaublichen
zeitlichen druck die müssen ja bezahlt
werden für für die für die texte das
heißt man muss viele klicks machen und
mit wenig zeit also schnell was raus
pumpen dinge stark darstellen oder so
also dass das kein unterbewusst in diese
richtung gehen kann das ist glaube ich
jedem klar also selbst wenn man sich
vornimmt
ich will jetzt nur das schreiben wie es
ganz nüchtern ist dann hat man im
hinterkopf aber mein chef ist schon
glücklicher wenn das ding mehr klicks
gibt und ich sollte schon so ein
bisschen spannender für den zuschauer
machen und ich habe auch nicht so die
zeit jetzt nochmal nachzukommen
natürlich passiert das dann der zweite
grund ist halt weil leute eine meinung
haben aber nicht die eier haben dass sie
sagen ich habe diese meinung also dass
sie sozusagen ein text in bestimmte
richtung lenken wollen und den followern
klar machen wollen wie eine bestimmte
sache ist obwohl sie eigentlich wenn sie
besser drauf werden sagen würden epos
auf liebe follower ich habe diese
meinung ich finde das so und so und ich
erkläre ich jetzt weshalb ich das so
findet das war eigentlich die cholera
hat
vielleicht ist das dadurch passiert dass
die etablierten medien immer
meinungsfreudige werden also das finde
ich wahnsinnig auffällig also man sich
mal spaßeshalber tagesschau von vor 30
jahren am guckt ja wo also quasi
roboterhaft ja wie ein automat wird
irgendwo im hintergrund sieht man den
dia und von gesichtern und politiker und
dann wird somit mit betonter
nüchternheit etwas referiert ja und dann
hat ja der amerikanische stil auch bei
unserem fernsehen einzug gehalten dass
die einkommen entstanden dass die
aufgewertet haben dass sie
interpretieren
das ist ja eine tendenz die starkes und
die sich durch die meinungsvielfalt im
netz wo jeder seine meinung raushauen
kann auch in den öffentlich rechtlichen
medien zum beispiel verstärkt hat und
übrigens auch in die qualitätszeitungen
also die die anzahl des des
meinungsjournalismus gegenüber dem
reinen nachrichtenjournalismus hat sich
ja enorm verändert ist das jetzt eine
band für seine schlechte entwicklung ist
erstmal eine nachvollziehbare und
entwicklung weil natürlich klicke ich
eher auf etwas drauf was mich entweder
aufregt oder wo eine meinung sozusagen
bestätigt wird dich selber habe also
eins von beidem klicke ich eher drauf
als wenn ich einfach nicht artikel lesen
insofern ist sozusagen rein
marktwirtschaftlich erst mal eine sache
für die nachvollziehbar ist und oben
drauf kommt dann auch das ist natürlich
viel leichter ist eine meinung zu haben
als sich mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen meine meinung kann
jeder haben und es kann man immer runter
schreiben und vor allen dingen wenn man
es dann was ja auch häufig in so
meinungsartikel dann vor vorkommt dass
man gegen eine gegenseite ein dass das
dass das argument führt dass man aber
unglaublich simplifiziert also man
schreibt einfach die ganzen klima
panikmacher die wollen ja sowieso nur
dass wir alle rad fahren und dann ist
natürlich sehr leicht da dagegen etwas
zu genau dass schau vertretern
wechselseitig wo genau und dann sagen
die wieder ja und die alten weiß männer
die wollen doch nur das und dann
argumentiert man gegen diese nur das was
super ganz dummer standpunkt ist und
dann hat man ziemlich leicht das heißt
es ist es ist nachvollziehbar war es
leicht ist und sich gut klingt aber wenn
ich zum beispiel das video die
zerstörung der cdu gemacht habe oder
auch der presse ich krieg nicht
ansatzweise die kohle raus dich da
reingesteckt nicht also nicht nicht mal
im haus ich mache das einfach weil ich
es für richtig halte weil ich cool finde
so ich steckte einfach viel zeit rein
und das ding ist klar könnte man jetzt
einmal du hast 17 millionen views
gemacht blablabla du hast das hat sich
ja gelohnt aber das wusste ja vorher
nicht dass sich das lohnt also deswegen
konnte ich ja nicht gemacht haben weil
ich wusste auch klar ich mache ein video
eine stunde über über politik das werden
dann ganz viele leute gucken natürlich
nicht ich habe davor auch schon solche
videos gemacht die halt nicht so viele
leute gesehen haben
das heißt das ist ein großer unterschied
zu leuten die sie zeitungsartikel
schreiben dass ich einfach sagen kann
ich setze jetzt extrem viel geld und
zeit in sand weil ich da einfach bock
drauf weil ich einfach finde dass das
gerade richtig ist so und ich glaube
also natürlich kann man es bei einer
zeitung auch mal aber ich glaube es
fällt mir leichter dass zu tun
weil ich letztlich kann ich mit meiner
zeit in meinem geld machen was ich will
so ich kann ja mein meinem team sagen
wie es derzeit die sagen ja ok cool du
musst mir das gesagt ist unabhängiger
und würdest du sagen youtube ist im
vergleich zu den etablierten medien
demokratische es ist schneller
demokratischer also die hemmschwelle
etwas zu deponieren wenn wir mit zeitung
seit zehn jahren kaufs und dann zu sagen
ach nee ich glaube die will ich doch
nicht mehr ich werde jedoch kein geld
mehr geben das braucht schon eine
bestimmte schwelle von ich finde die
zeitung nicht mehr gut aber zu sagen ich
gucke die videos nicht mehr von von
irgendwem das passiert relativ schnell
also insofern es ist beides insofern
schon demokratisch aber dass eine
sozusagen ein bisschen mittelbarer
demokratisch und das andere ist eher
unmittelbarer demokratisch bei ab dem
punkt wo ich wenn wenn wenn ich deine
videos nicht mehr sehen wollen würde
dann würdest du ab jetzt kein geld mehr
sozusagen durch mich kriegen ja aber das
natürlich diesen effekt dass es viele
leute gibt die einen möglichen scheiß
erzählen das heißt ja in deinem video
über die zerstörung der presse cc ein
paar falten auf oder rechnete mit denen
ab die quasi so was ähnliches machen wie
du also jetzt auch sachen von denen sie
nicht wissen wie ganz genau die
klickzahlen sind ja unabhängig sind die
kein ganzes verlagshaus hinter sich
haben und so und die sachen erzählen die
sie vermutlich nicht mal selber glauben
aber auf die art und weise eine
unglaubliche popularität erwirtschaften
wenn man das jetzt vergleich mit den
alten medien wird es unter dem strich
sagen dass diese veränderung der
medienlandschaft also die zunehmende
einfluss von meinungsmachern auf youtube
dass das alles in allem trotzdem besser
ist als das alte oder würdest du sagen
das kann man gar nicht entscheiden hier
ist ding ist hat beides halt stärken und
schwächen so also ich glaube ich glaube
es wäre es wäre quatsch zu sagen dass
das eine ist jetzt in allen punkten
besser und das ist jetzt einfach diese
neue welt und wir müssen in diese wir
sollten das anstreben ich glaube es ist
es gibt durchaus manche skills die die
sozusagen in den etablierten deutlich
mehr vorhanden sind was nicht heißt dass
sie nicht nicht vorhanden gar nicht
folgen sind auf auf youtube aber
grundsätzlich so zu sagen wenn es
irgendein thema gibt wo es
viel viel viel material erst mal zu gibt
dann können es die etablierten deutlich
besser schaffen sich die zeit und mühe
zu nehmen und das all star teams haben
wie der spiegel aber ja aber theoretisch
könnten leute das auf einer plattform
auch machen so aber das passiert halt
nicht so oft vielleicht liegt es daran
dass sie nicht so große teams haben mag
sein aber ich würde den schon den punkt
geben das dass sie diese skills einfach
besser können dass die sozusagen mit
einer gewissen qualität so einen
gewissen messlatte einfach ordentlich
recherchieren können
könntest du ja prinzipiell auch ne also
wenn ich jetzt wirtschaftlich wahnsinnig
erfolgreich wäre es bist und so weiter
mit dem was du machst könntest dir ein
team von 20 30 leuten haben die würden
für dich die gesamte recherche
übernehmen und dann wäre es zu einer
ähnlichen situation wie spiegel oder wie
ein großer fernsehsender
ja dann bin ich ja praktisch wie die
also dann bin ich jetzt genau wie die
ihr seid jetzt quasi eine ergänzung zum
bestehenden angebot und das wird
möglicherweise auch lange so bleiben
also die alten medien verschwinden nicht
sondern die neuen kommen einfach nur als
weitere säule dazu ja ich glaube dass
die neuen auch die alten ein stück weit
verändern werden also mantek dass manche
sachen funktionieren oder man manche
sachen nicht nicht sein müssen also klar
wenn man in bestimmten festen strukturen
drin ist gerade die alten medien sind ja
in vielen schon als als als die sz 9
ich glaube dass es nicht nur eine die
die ergänzung ist also das sozusagen
eine sache einfach bleibt vielleicht
müssen weniger wird in der in der in der
range und eine zweite sache dazu kommt
sondern dass die zweite sache auf jeden
fall verändert was die erste sache ist
ich stelle jetzt mal ein bisschen fiese
philosophische frage aller fragen ist
auch noch ja aber weil die geben
sozusagen die den pinienkernen ich geh
doch mal davon aus wenn du deine videos
macht also wir reden jetzt vor allem
über die politischen videos ja dass du
in irgendeiner form so weit ist
irgendwie möglich ist die wahrheit sagst
um eine philosophische frage ist was
verstehst du unter wahrheit eigentlich
ja das ist ne das ist eine krasse frage
bei dasding ist ich hab ja ich habe ja
in ich habe ja in informatik studiert
das heißt für mich gibt's schon
wahrheiten so aus der sicht also bei
allen bei vielen vielen wissenschaften
kannst wir theoretisch alles infrage
stellen also
weil viele vieles letztlich dann auf
messungen basiert und klar könnten die
auch theoretisch kann vieles in frage
stellen aber du kannst halt nachweisen
das weiß ich nicht alle geraden zahlen
durch zwei teilbar
das kann ich dir jetzt nachweisen und
dieses kleine dingen wenn da kein fehler
drin ist gilt das und zwar nicht nur
hier sondern überall im universum nun
auch zu jedem zeitarbeiter welt ja eine
sache wo wir es mit mit logik zu tun um
reine zahlen welt aber wenn wir jetzt
politik ja also macht die sache ja
schwieriger das war ja sagen wir seien
keine ganz ganz ganz exakten sicheren
messungen
hier können wir nicht mal eben das was
ich meine
mit der realität überprüfen weil die
realität das ist was unglaublich diffus
und komplex ist ich glaube auch dass das
in der heutigen zeit ist unglaublich
leicht macht für leute die sozusagen auf
billige art und weise täuschen wollen
demagogen haben es auf jeden fall sehr
sehr leicht in der heutigen zeit weil du
kannst dir mittlerweile für alles
irgendwie eine quelle suchen du kannst
mittlerweile für alles die irgendwas an
den haaren herbeiziehen und sagen ja
hier ist dieser eine wissenschaftler aus
den 80ern der hat das gesagt und für
irgendwen ist das voll der stronger
punkt leider nicht versteht wie wissen
geht so das heißt du überzeugt heute so
krass alleine wenn du in einem video sah
das gewaltige resonanz dahin ja also
große echo kammern wo pause heraus diese
meinung wieder begegnet wird so oft dass
ich danach er felsenfest davon überzeugt
dass genau das stimmt und der ganze rest
lich aber der aber der knackpunkt daran
ist eigentlich dass wir niemals in
unserer in unserer gesellschaft gelernt
haben mit medien umzugehen und mit den
den mit mit schlussfolgerungen umzugehen
also wir lernen logik mini in der nie in
der schule wir lernen niemals über was
wir für neues haben also was da im wir
uns unter den eigenen austrickst das
wissen wir alle nicht das wissen das
weiß jemand nicht der 20 ist das weiß
nicht jemand der 50 die meisten leute
wissen darüber nicht das heißt das ist
eine große schwierigkeit und leute
können mit medien nicht nicht nicht
nicht umgehen aber auch weil sie es nie
gelernt haben weil das bisher
bisher war in zeitung war früher der
grand einfach was zu sagen und dann ja
die leute glauben uns halt wenn wir das
schreiben dann ist das so
das heißt leute sind aufgewachsen mit
der denkstruktur wenn mir jemand etwas
überzeugend rüber bringt er sagt das ist
so ja dann ist das wohl so und das ding
bis heute ist es doch so dass wenn ich
dass ich in artikeln teilweise lese eine
studie aus den usa fand jetzt das und
das raus und ich denke ja welche studie
wo ist der link via wo ist die denn
zeig mir doch und ich das absurd finde
dass wir immer noch nicht an dem punkt
angekommen sind wo auch die alten medien
aber natürlich die neuen auch einfach
mal wenn ich was sage sollte ich
vielleicht quelle dazu eingeben wenn ich
was sage soll ich das belegen sollte ich
sagen hier wie kommst du dahinter zu
überprüfen kannst was ich sage denn wenn
wir einen punkt sind dass wir irgendwie
glauben müssen einfach was was irgendwer
sagt dann macht es keinen unterschied
mehr wer das sagt dann denn das ist kein
guter punkt einfach ist dass die
forderung des aufklärers dass wir mehr
aufklärung in der schule brauchen also
dass das menschen in der schule nicht
vernünftig lernen mit informationen
umzugehen kommentare meinungen zu
unterscheiden von fakten und nachrichten
und das sagt quasi im mittelpunkt oder
einer der schwerpunkte jeder
schulbildung sein sollte voll ich glaube
nicht einmal dass kommentare von fakten
unterscheiden das lernt man sogar
teilweise in deutschland war ich glaube
ich so was glaube ich kommt sogar vor
aber logisches denken also kann also
teilweise stehen in zeitungsartikeln
drin er sagt das und das also sagt er
das und das und du denkst nein dass die
schlussfolgerung ist gar nicht da ist
die logische implikation wirklich diese
nein ist es nicht und die meisten leute
sind nie darin ausgebildet worden die
meisten leute die in der presse arbeiten
sind auch nie daran aus aus nie darin
ausgebildet worden dass es ja nicht
schlimm müssen sie ja nicht sein so aber
das ist natürlich sagt auch nicht jeder
logik apolitisch die wahrheit gilt ja
auch noch ich bin also natürlich können
leute im journalismus logisch denken
aber sie sind nicht daran ausgebildet
natürlich kann ich journalistisch denken
aber ich bin nicht daran ausgewertet das
macht schon einen unterschied und das
ist das eine das dass ich mich um das
massiv stört wie unfassbar
die meisten leute in logik sind und dass
sie nicht verstehen waren eine logische
implikation da ist und dann hätte er
sofort ein männchen warum das so ist
ich weiß nicht ob die region james was
sagt william james war in der vorletzten
jahrhundertwende also um das jahr 1900
im berühmtesten philosoph der welt
gleichzeitig die führende psychologe der
welt also seine principles of psychology
waren der renner der damaligen zeit und
william james ist der vater des us
amerikanischen pragmatismus
so aber pragmatismus jetzt nicht im
landläufigen sinne sondern die theorie
dahinter steht ist folgendes unser
denken verdankt sich hatte sich intensiv
mit darwin beschäftigt ja das kommt ja
von unseren vorfahren und so für unsere
vorfahren war wichtig dass wir uns in
der savanne die wasserlöcher merken
konnten und orientieren konnten und der
wahrheit' begriff der war von anfang an
an die orientierungsfunktion gekoppelt
das heißt also wahrheit aber nur in dem
sinne wichtig dass ich weiß da ist das
wasserloch damit ich morgen wieder hin
finde und daraus zieht er die konsequenz
dass er sagt die eigentliche wurzel der
wahrheit für die menschen ist die
nützlichkeit also das was für die unsere
orientierung nützliches das ist das was
wir dann auch irgendwann für wahrheit
halten so das kann man auf
unterschiedlichem niveau machen das kann
man auf unterstem niveau machen sind wir
bei donald trump ja alles was für mich
nützlich ist stimmt auch aber kann es
auch auf höherem niveau machen und sagen
das geht nicht um praktische
nützlichkeit es geht darum dass es
zweckdienlich ist etwas zu glauben oder
nicht zu glauben also im sinne von wenn
mir jemand sagt ein guter freund ist
gestorben ist das eine blöde information
aber es wäre total dumm wenn ich jetzt
sage die ist nicht nützlich für mich die
glaube ich nicht sondern es geht darum
seine grundsätzliche orientierung in der
welt zu erhalten um mein eindruck ist
immer wenn deutsche medien nutzen geht
es um einen pragmatischen begriff von
wahrheit also das was bestätigt was ich
schon vorher gedacht habe hat eine
riesen hohe wahrscheinlichkeit von mir
als war erachtet zu werden und das was
irgendwie mich irritiert oder was mein
weltbild infrage gestellt das wird von
anfang an als wahrheit aussortiert ist
es nicht so dass wir im grunde genommen
die neuen medien wo man durch die
kommentare auch immer sieht was die
leute darüber denken
unglaublich eindrucksvoll demonstrieren
dass die menschen so denken wie william
james das beschrieben
ja also wie stimmig völlig zu auch ich
sagte ja gerade dass die andere sache
die mich stört ist dass leute nicht in
der schule darüber lernen was für ein
bayer sie haben und den confirmation
beißen du gerade angesprochen hast das
definitiv einer dem man definitiv in der
schule lernen sollte ein anderer ist
auch noch ein beispiel dafür dass
sozusagen die vorfahren dass sich nun
eine nützliche denkstruktur einfach sehr
festgefahren hat nämlich neigen menschen
ja total stark dazu hinter allem eine
autonome kraft zu sehen also zu zufälle
gibt es nicht sondern steckt
irgendjemand ursache genau das ist auch
total nachvollziehbar weil die affen im
wald die bei einem knappen dachten oder
kommt ein bär sind hier die haben er
überlebt als die die gedacht haben ist
bestimmt nur zufall insofern kann ich
auch da nachvollziehen dass das so ist
aber diese sachen müssen jedoch in der
schule lernen also das finde ich ist
doch ein klavier müssen wir uns selber
aufgeklärt werden ja das sind wir uns
sehr häufig mit sehr simplen erklärung
von ursachen zufriedengeben hauptsache
wir haben einen gefunden und das hat er
auch eine basis für verschwörungs
erzählung her
ja weil die machen einfach unglaublich
kompliziert die dinge ganz einfach total
und man gehört zu den wenigen die es
verstehen das fühlt sich schon mal gut
an
also da gibt es ganz viele sachen die da
einfach sich gut anfühlt aber zu wissen
dass der eigene körper und den kopf
sozusagen dazu neigt und zu wissen was
für fehler man wahrscheinlich machen
wird das ist glaub ich das aber dass das
problem ist selbst wenn wir jetzt das
schulsystem so umstellen würden und es
ist jetzt nicht so als würden wir den ex
paar jahren schaffen dazu sind wirklich
fürchterlich ich fürchte auch nicht aber
sie ist nehmen wir mal an wie sehr auch
nicht das einzige was für ein
verändertes steuersystem aber selbst
wenn wir das schaffen würden und wir in
zehn jahren irgendwie die die leute die
dann nachkommen so ausbilden dass sie
sowas wissen der sich einfach besser mit
informationen umgehen können weil sie
diese skills haben dann dauert es ja
noch 80 jahre bis die ausgestorben sind
dies gilt nicht haben also das hat ja
einen riesigen rattenschwanz und wie
kommen wir dazu dass die leute die jetzt
nicht in der schule sind die das noch
lernen und damit meine ich jetzt nicht
die alten ich meine auch die 30-jährigen
ich meine auch die 20-jährige ich meine
nicht nur die 60 jährige
nein kein plan dass dinge die die sind
alle bis sie die haben alle was zu tun
wie willst du die denn dazu bringen dass
die sagen ja immer
freizeit da lerne ich jetzt mal neue
skills und hinterfrage mich mal
nachmittags so das passiert ja nicht
wenig was jährige nach
schicksalsschlägen partnerin verlässt
sein oder so man stellt sich einmal ganz
grundsätzlich in frage was habe ich
alles mein leben falsch gemacht also das
sind so momente aber solange die normale
lebens geschmeidigkeit nicht
beeinträchtigt wird stellen menschen
sich herr gemeinhin sehr sehr sehr
ungern in frage das ist ein zustand den
wir ja auch nicht gut aushalten
also wird diese in diesem zustand dass
wir denken ich habe den ganzen mist
erzählt dass es irgendwas da denke ich
darüber nach ob ich mir patricks haben
in denen ich die geschichte wieder
begradigen ist aber nicht gerade sehr
viel klar welche finde es super
nachvollziehbar das ist fühlt sich auch
scheiße an aber das sehe ich um wieder
den bogen zu schlagen zu den neuen und
den alten medien da sehe ich habe ja
gerade ein paar vorteile aufgezählt von
den medien nur so aber dass ich den
vorteil in den neuen medien weil dort
die die ehrlichkeit ehrlich zu sich
selbst sein und auch nicht sachen
sozusagen erst jahre später dann auf zu
aufzuarbeiten sondern wirklich zu sagen
er weiß was das was ich gestern
geschrieben aber auf twitter das war
mist so dass das treibt leute er also
die die neuen medien treibt leute glaube
ich eher dazu klar direkt fehler
einzugestehen als die alten medien bei
allen medien war es so wenn ich in der
zeitung halt in den siebzigerjahren
irgendwas schreibe den griechen paar
leserbriefe muss ich eigentlich nichts
dazu sagen dann aber wenn ich auf das
erst mal zwei oder mehr unter
rechtfertigungszwang heute steht genau
aber dass also das ist auch was
schlechtes in manchen hinsicht aber ich
werde das man wahnsinnig am pranger
gestellt er total total total ist kann
sie auch alles kann ich auch schlecht
auswirken aber ich sehe darin schon den
vorteil weil ich habe das gefühl dass
weil dadurch dass man so viel nicht mehr
also wenn man sich mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen will kann man jedem
jeder jede jede sicht hören da kann man
auch quellen für jede sicht höher und
man weiß gar nicht mehr was man glauben
will umso wichtiger ist es ja dass man
leuten vertrauen kann das wirklich dass
das ich glaube einem menschen ich habe
das gefühl diese person setzt sich damit
auseinander und die person würde mich
das ist ein unterschied zu früher dass
der mensch als ganzes jetzt die quelle
der glaubwürdigkeit wird also sehr so
eine forderung die wir heute haben wir
der iso das und das und das macht dann
sollte aber auch so und so leben und der
soll das sind das nicht machen und ich
hoffe nicht dass er jetzt fleisch ist
und so also dass ich ein gesamtes ethik
paket damit du wirklich der gute bis dem
ich vertrauen kann ja und das war ja
früher nicht so also man hat ja früher
übrigens auch nicht von politikern
erwartet dass sie privat wahnsinnig
anständig und korrekt center in diesen
anspruch gibt es noch gar nicht lange
also durch ich würde sagen wir es erst
den letzten zehn 15 jahren überhaupt
erst so krasse entstanden den grafen es
früher nicht
und es ist natürlich immer schwieriger
glaubwürdig zu bleiben je mehr jemand
über die ich weiß ja also wenn du von
morgens bis abends bekannt und überwacht
und alles sieht man weiß und was sie da
noch gemacht was man da noch gemacht
hast dann stehst du ja ständig in gefahr
ja dieses dieses podest auf dem du dann
stehst und was du brauchst damit die
leute dir vertrauen das kann ganz ganz
ganz schnell unter den füßen weggezogen
werden es sei denn man ist ehrlich und
baut keine grobe scheiß und wenn man
große scheiße baut dann steht man dazu
weil man ehrlich ist ich glaube das ist
halt das wichtige aber die frage ist was
das grobe scheiße es kann ja sein dass
so ein paar dinge gemacht die sie selber
gar nicht so schlimm findet aber nicht
unerheblicher teil der fans schlimm
findet ja es kann schon passieren aber
ich meine ja okay dann dann ist
letztlich die frage bin aber dann kannst
du immer sagen dass immer leute dich
feiern egal was du machst dann kannst du
ja auch also im konzept mal sagen egal
was du tust egal wie schlecht das ist es
wird immer ein paar leute geben die das
gut finden aber ich glaube schon dass
wenn es den dass es nicht nur in den
hardcore-fans sozusagen von irgendwem
kam es glaube ich übergreifen trotzdem
ein konsens gefühl geben ob jemand jetzt
glaubwürdig ist oder nicht und ich
glaube das hängt sehr sehr stark nicht
nur davon ab wie ethisch verhält der der
mensch sich sondern wie ehrlich geht er
mit den fehlern um ist ja auch eine
freiheit nicht in allem privat sichtbar
zu sein also intransparenz ist ein
wichtiges freiheitsrecht ja und dass man
sagen kann in der rolle bin ich dann so
und so und so und wenn ich dann privat
bin ich ein bisschen anders und so ist
ja auch eine freiheit die man eigentlich
hatte das gefühl dass diese
freiheit immer mehr verloren je höher
dieser rundherum authentizität anspruch
wird ich glaube nicht dass sie verloren
geht man sieht sie ja nun nicht man soll
sie ja nicht sehen also das heißt wenn
ich jetzt die freiheit habe dass ich in
meiner in meiner freizeit weiß ich nicht
eine eine liebesbeziehung zu fünf
unterschiedlichen männern habe zehn
unterschiedliche kinder habe und mir am
wochenende im imberg im berghain pillen
schmeiße ihr kriegt es nicht mit ich
habe die freiheit das zu tun aber
natürlich siehst du diese freiheit nicht
weil ich die geheim halten würde wenn
ich sie so ausleben wollen würde als
eine freiheit das heißt du hast den du
hast den bayers dass du sozusagen die
freiheitlich ausgelebten sachen gar
nicht wahrnimmst weil sie nur
freiheitlich sind wenn du sie nicht
wahrnehmen was mich noch als als großes
thema beschäftigt und beschäftigt mich
wirklich sehr stark dass der begriff
öffentlichkeit also öffentlichkeit
bedeutet dass relativ viele menschen
über das gleiche reden
also das ist die herstellung von
öffentlichkeit das war also unsere
vorstellung von öffentlichkeit stammt
eigentlich aus dem weiten griechenland
in der police da trafen sich die freien
griechischen männer ja die trafen sich
dann jeden tag eigentlich und redeten
über die angelegenheiten des staates und
des handels so was weiß ich was und das
siege brachte zumindest für die elite im
damaligen griechenland eine vorstellung
auf der agora auf dem markt
öffentlichkeit herzustellen
im mittelalter war nicht so viel mit
öffentlichkeit da gab es eine kleine
funktionseliten die eben als quasi nach
wissenschaftlicher kaderplanung dann
zehn jahre nach paris geschickt wurde
und da ausgebildet und so und hat eine
richtige öffentlichkeit die
intellektuelle jedenfalls gab es nicht
und in der renaissance kommt sozusagen
diese alte police gedanke wieder zurück
und auf der italienischen piazza in
mittelitalien entsteht unsere heutige
vorstellung von öffentlichkeit dass man
über die angelegenheiten des handelns
und des handels ganz besonders in
italien usw sich unterhält und aus
dieser öffentlichkeit entstehen
irgendwann die zeitung siebzehnten
jahrhundert in deutschland und in
leipzig die erste zeitung messeplatz ja
handelsplätze und und da kommt diese
öffentlichkeit her
die ist aber angewiesen darauf dass die
leute die gleichen themen haben
jetzt haben wir eine so unglaubliche
medienvielfalt und so eine interessen
vielfalt dass sich jeder bequem in
seinem eigenen segment aufhalten kann
und mit den anderen segmenten eigentlich
gar nicht unbedingt berührungspunkte
haben muss und da könnte es ja rein
theoretisch passieren dass das
gemeinsame ein thema ja dass das immer
weniger wird und das sozusagen die
einzel welt in der ich lebe ob das jetzt
ein echo kamera sind oder einen
speziellen interessen dass das immer
mehr wird und es war immer eines der
stärksten argumente für die etablierten
medien öffentlich rechtliches fernsehen
und große zeitungen zu sagen wir bündeln
das noch wir stellten öffentlichkeit her
wir haben themen wir greifen die themen
auf wo die leute sich alle mit dem
gleichen beschäftigen und verhindert die
zersplitterung jetzt gehen diese medien
aber deutlich runter und die frage wäre
können die neuen medien auf ähnliche art
und weise öffentlichkeit schaffen oder
wenn sie das nicht können
er ist eine gute frage weil innerhalb
von sozusagen meiner szene meiner
online-szene so gibt es sehr große
öffentlichkeit also jetzt gerade vor ein
paar tagen ist gab es ein fall wo es
anschuldigungen wegen sexuellen
übergriffen wegen grenz ganz ganz
grenzüberschreitung gab und es haben
millionen leute mitbekommen in den
klassischen wenigen kein mensch so aber
bei uns bei uns haben es millionen leute
mit bekommen es ging so weit dass nachts
um 2 uhr nur eine nüchterne kommentare
zu dem thema von 50.000 leuten live zu
gesehen wurden nachts um zwei also es
war ein wichtiges ding für viele viele
menschen in den klassischen medien kam
es überhaupt nicht vor kriegen davon
nichts mit
und was mir das so ein bisschen gezeigt
hat war es ist eigentlich schade dass
die davon nichts mitbekommen weil es
wäre gut gewesen wenn die sich da
einlässt wäre gut gewesen diese externe
sicht darauf zu haben dass sozusagen die
klassischen auf den sachverhalt drauf
kommen weil die leute die in meiner
szene darüber gesprochen haben die canon
irgendwen der damm in den stores mit
drin war und irgendwie ist man so ein
bisschen zu nah dran selbst wenn man die
leute nicht kennt es ist die gleiche
szene und man keine ahnung
und es ist eigentlich eigentlich ist es
ganz cool so verschiedene levels zu
haben wenn sie denn nicht einfach nix
von von phoenix nichts voneinander mit
kriegen sondern in solchen fällen
einfach sich mal überschneiden würden
und mal sozusagen als externe sich drauf
gucken das ist natürlich ein sehr
schwieriges system weil man muss sie ja
dann was von voneinander mit mitkriegen
und das auch in den richtigen
augenblicken und zweitens ist ein sehr
instabiles system weil die externe sicht
auch dazu führen kann dass man dinge
falsch einschätzt und dann gibt es einen
streit zwischen den bubble ist natürlich
wenn mir einer von externen ankommt und
mir die welt erklären will dann kann ich
verstehen dass das auch also das würde
in jede richtung leute bis ich machen
das heißt ich glaube es dieses
aufsplitten hat nicht nur
schwierigkeiten also es kann mir jetzt
nicht mehr nicht mehr ändern dass das
ist die welt in der wir jetzt leben dass
es mehr alles auf mehr alles aufbietet
gibt es sozusagen kleinere super babbels
gibt ja also diese angst hass menschen
eigentlich keine information mehr
vertrauen aber ein unbegrenztes
vertrauen in die eigene meinung kann das
scheint sicher im augenblick zu
verstärken vielleicht war das immer
schon so monats früher nicht gemerkt das
ist durchaus möglich ja aber von dem was
man sieht wirkt es so als wenn es sich
wahnsinnig verstärkt also sage nochmal
der der weg zur eindeutigen meinung der
scheint immer kürzer zu werden
jedenfalls sofern man das medial
wahrnehmen kann
das kann ich nicht einschätzen ob der
kürzer geworden ist weil er nicht früher
auch kurz also ich weiß nicht wie es
sich angefühlt habe in den achtzigern
zeitung zu lesen aber ich hab ja sofort
schlägt es auf dasteht fallen so ist die
welt dreht sich wahrscheinlich selber
also der durchschnittlich hier
zeitungsleser nicht getraut diese
meinung außerhalb des bekanntenkreises
allzu laut kund zu tun
das war der große unterschied er so kurz
war es vielleicht schon aber man war
vorsichtiger und das zweite ist man
hatte vor institutionen vermutlich mehr
respekt ob das gut oder schlecht das
kann lange drüber diskutieren aber dass
viele gesagt haben na ja wenn das da und
da steht dann wird das schon stimmen
diese haltung ist verloren gehen da tat
sich etwas gutes und schlechtes ja aber
da gibt es bestimmt eine große
veränderung
dahingehend sich auch die fans glauben
nur dass jetzt rein die die
meinungsbildung der lenkeinschlag was
auf ich lesen sagt jetzt ist es halt
genauso ich glaube sogar dass er jetzt
eher länger geworden ist weil dadurch
also sehe ich auf jeden fall bei den
jüngeren die können halt mit medien
bisschen besser umgehen und die kennen
die haben eher den anspruch dass sie
sagen das ist fake also dass sie irgend
einfach spiel der letten bild hoch und
da sieht man irgendwas draufkommt dass
wirklich daher das ist fake das machen
leute aus der presse auch aber so der
durchschnitt 50 jährige macht dass mein
bauchgefühl nach weniger als der
durchschnitt 20 jährige bei der
durchschnitt 20 jährige der keinen sehr
viele fakes der ist aufgewachsen mit
fakes nicht mit ich lese was dann wird
zum stimmigen was ist wenn der
durchschnitt 20 jährige dann irgendwann
so gut wie keiner quelle mehr traut das
könnte ich auch das ergebnis die folge
ist nicht dass die keiner quelle mehr
trauen sondern die folge ist dass das
verhalten sich einfach so weit ändert
dass man mehr ansprüche hat an entweder
zeigt mir eine quelle oder ich glaub es
wieder nur diesen menschen in dem ich
schon seit jahren glaube weil ich merke
dass er mich nicht verarscht was ja
letztlich das selbstvertrauen ist wie
damals in einer zeitung oder auch
heutzutage noch immer steckt jetzt mal
ganz großer optimismus hinter oder was
klingt ja jetzt sehr positiv
ich glaube schon ich glaube dieser
teilaspekt den finde ich sehr sehr schön
dass er sich also dass bei jüngeren
leuten sozusagen der anspruch an
nachweisbarkeit auf jeden fall steigt es
ist traurig dass es passiert weil seit
die welt voller sex ist aber und es ist
natürlich ist es nicht so dass es jeder
junge mensch mache ich meine jetzt nur
in der groben tendenz aber ich will und
die andere geschichte die angst vor der
zersplitterung der öffentlichkeit dass
die menschen sich nicht mehr genug im
gleichen segment aufhalten um doch über
das gleiche zu reden
du hattest jetzt als beispiel eine
community es genannt genau hier habe
aber diese welt dieser community ist
natürlich eine andere welt als die welt
in der 60-jährigen oder sogar wie viele
berührungspunkte aber das war gerade da
mein mein punkt das sozusagen die die
die alten leute oder die leute in
anderen babbel die kriegten dieses thema
was jetzt für viele leute die
wahrscheinlich dann eher so 30 oder
darunter sind ein thema war gar nicht
mit aber ich glaube dass es positiv
gewesen wäre wenn sie sich überschnitten
hätten
das heißt es liegt ein bisschen an uns
allen dass wir dafür sorgen sozusagen in
andere babbels vorzudringen und auch mal
zu wagen in anderen babbels reinzugehen
und ich glaube dafür ist zum einen
wichtig dass man sich selbst nicht zu
ernst nimmt dass man ich denke aber wir
sind ja eigentlich die so also ich würde
unterstellen das ist bei den klassischen
medien sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
dieses gefühl gibt als bei den neuen
dass man das gefühl hat ja wieso sollte
ich jetzt hin zu denen hingehen wieso
soll ich jetzt das youtube video rein
gehen oder so aber ich glaube dass das
dass wir sozusagen das ausspielen von
bubbles nicht mehr ändern können wir
müssen nur damit umgehen und dass das
umgehen sollte sein dass wir sozusagen
hin und her hoffen so ein bisschen
könnte der meinungsjournalismus bei
youtube irgendwas für den künftigen
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt beitrage
du hast gerade gesagt wird dass müsste
passieren irgendeine idee wie na ja
alleine da sich die jetzt hier sitze ist
doch schon ein gutes angebot ein
friedensangebot ist ja nicht so als
games krieg aber es ist schon ein einig
kann ein bisschen hier schnuppern
ihr könnt ein bisschen schnuppern es ist
so ein bisschen sicher ist es ein
anderes ist ein es ist ein austausch es
ist einfach ich komme aus einer anderen
welt du kommst aus meiner perspektive
aus einer welt oder hier alle
und das ist ich glaube das ist was gutes
das ist schon so schritte die einfach
gut und insofern ja das wäre meine idee
dass man einfach so ein bisschen
wirklich hin und her schnuppert dass
auch leute die auf dem posten aus dem
aus dem fernsehen kommen einfach mal
sagen okay ich mache jetzt mal bei einem
live stream mit ich mache ich guck mal
in diese welt rein oder das auch
presseleute einfach mal gucken
die haben jetzt über irgendeine sache
einfach in live streams diskussion
geführt das macht man doch so vielleicht
eigentlich nicht aber ich gucke mir mal
an ich guck mal wie die das machen
vielleicht können wir ja was mitnehmen
davon
ich glaube in alle richtungen kann man
da schon viel machen wenn man jetzt auch
wenn das immer schwierig erst mal einen
kleinen sprung in 30 jahren machen dann
bin ich wenn ich noch lieber ein sehr
alter mann du bist dann so alt wie ich
und die frage ist werden dann in die
leute die in deinem alter sind wenn die
bei youtube sein oder ist schon
irgendwas am horizont zu sehen was an
die stelle von
sozialen medien wie youtube dann treten
wird ich hoffe das was an der stelle
getreten wird nicht nicht weil ich jetzt
nicht weil ich youtube hasse aber weil
ich einfach feier wenn die welt sich
weiterentwickelt und wenn es etwas neues
gibt und ich glaube einfach sozusagen
aus einer grund künstlerischen sicht
heraus glaube ich es gibt immer mehr es
gibt immer noch ideen es gibt immer noch
ansätze die besser sind stehen zu
bleiben mit einem mit mit einem so
machen wir das jetzt für die nächsten
jahrzehnte wird die generation deiner
kinder die zerstörung von youtube
betreiben wieso ich danke dir für das
gespräch
[Musik]
münchen